el epílogo del congreso del partido
comunista ha servido para certificar el
tercer mandato de Pin como secretario
general y la renovación de la jefatura
en la comisión militar son los dos
cargos más importantes del país y es más
que probable que en marzo sea investido
por tercera vez presidente del gobierno
todo eso ya se daba por sentado hoy
consistía en responder a otras dos
preguntas la primera es como de plural
iba a ser el comité permanente por lo
que hemos visto en el paseíllo con el
que se ha presentado esta mañana lo va a
ser muy poco todos son fieles de sí
probablemente el nombre que más
sorprende es el de Lee Jean que gestionó
la calamitosa lucha contra el covid en
Shanghai no estará sin embargo justo un
Juan que era la persona que se habían
puesto todas las esperanzas de que en el
comité hubiera algo de variedad este
congreso ha servido para finiquitar la
influencia de los dos grandes clanes que
habían mandado en la política china
durante las últimas décadas uno es el
clan de Shanghai liderado por
presidente Jam semín de 96 años El otro
es los tuampay o la liga juvenil
encabezado por el ex presidente también
huyentao que ayer en un acto cargado de
simbolismo tuvo que ser evacuado del
Gran palacio del pueblo probablemente
por problemas de salud la otra cuestión
que se ventilaba esta mañana era si el
comité iba a contar con algo parecido a
un sucesor o un delfín no parece que lo
haya Así que es muy probable que sí sin
fin no vaya a cumplir solo uno sino dos
mandatos así que se jubilaría con 79
años